-We are here with Oscar Gil,
the head bartender at Scampi
in New York City.
Give it up for Oscar, everybody.
And he's gonna teach us
how to make
some delicious gin cocktails
in honor of
Hillary "Gin" Meyers...
[ Laughter ]
...right over there.
Thanks so much
for being here, Oscar.
-Thank you for having me.
It's a pleasure.
-I think we should maybe
get her one right off the bat.
-Absolutely.
-It's been a long day.
[ Laughter ]
-It's always a good time
for a gin and tonic, right?
-Always.
-So we're gonna go ahead
and fill it up with ice.
-Okay. I think we know
how to do gin and tonic.
-Oh, yeah? Great.
[ Laughter ]
-You knock this one out,
and then we'll move on
to the tricky stuff.
-All right.
The one that's coming up,
it's even better.
-Okay, good, good, good.
We're very excited
for a trickier drink.
Hey, Josh, before we move on,
I forgot to ask.
You can go ahead
and keep making that.
You have
a Pee Wee Herman podcast.
-Oh, yeah.
Friday night, on KCRW,
and then
for a week afterwards,
but a live
Pee Wee Herman podcast.
I'm old friends
with Paul Reubens,
was in the
Pee Wee on Broadway show,
and so Pee Wee
is taking over KCRW
for an hour of -- of music.
There are gonna be
some great guests.
Some puppets might stop by.
So tune in for that.
Should be fun.
-There we go.
Pee Wee podcast.
-Yeah.
-All right.
Now, you --
Now that my mom has a drink,
what are we gonna make?
-All right.
So we're gonna do
a Corpse Reviver Number 2.
-What's it called?
-Corpse Reviver Number 2.
-Yeah.
-Okay. Why is it called
the Corpse Reviver?
-Well, the thing,
it's a drink meant
for, like,
after hung-- hangover.
-Okay, great. That'll come
in handy for us. Let's go.
-So it's picking you up.
So, we're gonna start with...
Actually, we're gonna
squeeze a lemon in it.
-All right.
We'll start with a lemon.
-Yeah, we squeeze
a full lemon in it.
-Okay.
-Yeah, sure.
-Give me half your lemon.
-A whole lemon is going in here?
-A whole lemon?
What are you talking about?
-So it's supposed to be equal
parts all the way through.
-Okay.
-So it's --
We're gonna 3/4, 3/4, 3/4
in the small thing.
-All right.
-Perfect.
-There we go.
Look right?
Equal parts of what?
-Can this bring
the other Addy back?
-Yeah, so...
[ Laughter ]
-It would be great
if she came back
and just pointed a bony finger
at Dad -- "You..."
[ Laughter ]
"...will learn to stand
for your elders!"
-Awesome.
Yeah, so we do lemon.
-Okay.
-Apéritif of cocchi americano.
Apéritif of cocchi americano.
-And then we --
yes, in equal parts.
-Equal parts. Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Eyeball it. Why not?
-Eyeball it, great.
A little gins.
-Some gin for you.
-Okay. Equal parts.
Equal parts.
There we go.
I think I'm very good
at getting equal parts,
equal parts.
There we go.
Orange liqueur, orange liqueur.
Equal parts.
-He's like, "I don't know."
-I'm a little nervous.
-Wait. Why are you
putting more lemon in?
-Because I had not done it.
-Oh, you haven't done it yet.
Well, you got to stick with us.
-I know, right?
[ Laughter ]
You guys are too fast for me.
-Okay, great.
And what is this exactly?
-So, this is actually
a fortified liqueur.
It's an Italian spirit,
and it's used, like, to mix.
-All right.
So what are we doing now?
-We're gonna fill it up
with ice.
-Okay, great.
-Is this a sweet one?
This one here?
-No, it's more --
I mean, by itself, it's gonna be
a little bit sweet, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
But that's why we mix it.
-Okay, great.
Now what do we do now?
-After that, we're gonna
close the bin.
-Close the bin.
-Uh-oh.
-Perfect.
-Are you worried?
-And you shake it?
Give it a nice shake.
-Don't splash you.
-Don't splash you?
[ Laughter ]
What would ever go wrong
for you to get splashed?
-I don't know.
-Awesome.
-No -- [ Laughs ]
-What happened?
-Standing back.
She's just worried about that.
-Oh!
-What are you talking about?
-I just saw some water.
Was your Friday
the 13th cocktail?
-I'm stuck.
I need a professional.
-So what you do is,
you just got through the side
and then open it?
-Okay, great.
-That's what I mean --
a professional.
-And you're gonna use
the strainer to put it in.
-There we go.
-Awesome.
-Okay, great.
-And you could spray
a little lemon.
It's pre-peeled, so...
I feel like
more came off yours.
-These are post-peeled?
-Professional.
-So, you do the front layer.
-Okay.
That one's the one...
-Okay, great.
Here we go. All right.
-Perfect.
-And now as that is it?
-That's it, yeah.
-Okay. So now let's see who you
think made the best one, Mom.
-Oh, gosh.
-Well, this is actually
gonna be a competition now.
-All right. So do I have
to close my eyes or...?
-No.
Mine. You'll like this one.
-Well, because
you see it's him now.
[ Laughter ]
-Have a sip of it.
You let them know.
-I'm guessing I'm not gonna win.
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-Let's see who's the favorite.
-It was never in the cards.
-Okay. Interesting.
-Okay.
-I think you were a little heavy
on the ingredients.
-Okay. But, you know,
he was always your favorite.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no, it was always him.
-Come on.
Even they just met him
and they don't believe you.
[ Laughter ]
-Ugh.
-Now, I'm -- I'm bad at reading
facial expressions.
[ Laughter ]
Could you put that into words?
-Oh, not so good.
-Okay.
-I'm not optimistic, Larry.
[ Laughter ]
-There's hope.
Keep hope alive.
-There's nowhere near
enough liquor in there.
-He poured it all in.
[ Laughter ]
-Right here, the winner.
-Try Oscar's, try Oscar's.
-Oh, wait a minute.
Oh, wait.
That's right.
-Good luck, buddy.
Good luck.
[ Laughter ]
Could be "Oscar Meyers."
-Oh, I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
That might be it.
-Yeah, well, that would track.
-Good job.
Nice job. Delicious.
-Give it up for Oscar.
It takes a lot for my mom
not to pick one of her boys.
You can order your own
Corpse Survivor at Scampi
in New York City.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."